depuis plusieurs jours Damien Rieu
ex-condidat reconquête au législatives
partage sur les réseaux sociaux des
photos et des vidéos de personnes qu'ils
décrit comme musulmane en train de prier
dans des espaces publics peut-être
faudrait-il suggérer à la RATP un
règlement invitant les passagers appris
avec légèrement plus de discrétion sauf
que certains seins surgent en affirmant
qu'il ne s'agit que de mise en scène et
de contenu trompeurs pour résumer la
méthode d'Amiens c'est du buzz du clash
et des trolls et cette semaine le
militant d'extrême droite a partagé une
nouvelle photo d'un homme en train de
prier au sein du tribunal judiciaire de
Paris mais cette photo a été en réalité
envoyée par un journaliste pour le
piéger et je voulais démontrer à partir
de cette petite vidéo que tu te fous
bien de notre gueule une séquence qui
est immédiatement fait le buzz un
journaliste piège un militant avec une
fausse prière peut-on jouer avec la
religion
merci encore illogen d'être avec nous
vous êtes journaliste indépendant qui a
piégé Damien Rieux alors on va voir la
vidéo bien sûr qui a pesé regardez
salut Damien je suis Cory je suis blanc
breton catholique et aussi journaliste
et je voulais démontrer à partir de
cette petite vidéo que tu te fous bien
de notre gueule voilà désolé mille
excuses à tous nos compatriotes
musulmanes et musulmans
voilà alors vous l'avez piégé le
raconter à nos téléspectateurs comment
vous avez eu l'idée en fait ça fait
depuis quelques temps que l'identitaire
d'extrême droite Damien qui est un
supposé être un lanceur d'alerte
#clone diffuse depuis un certain nombre
de jours des personnes il photographie
des ou alors il reçoit sur son compte
Twitter des gens qui auraient croisé des
personnes soi-disant priant dans la rue
ou dans les transports il y a eu une
affaire effectivement dans la
bibliothèque ce que vous avez derrière
vous et puis aussi dans le RER A ou
beaucoup d'utilisateurs utilisatrices de
rera ont dénoncé que c'était un menteur
puisqu'il s'agissait finalement d'un
mendiant le but alors j'étais au
tribunal de judiciaire de Paris le tout
nouveau lundi dernier pour effectivement
couvrir une audience en tant que
journaliste et je suis tombé sur de
nouveau une photo de lui qu'il avait
posté sur son compte Twitter et j'ai eu
la petite voix et il y avait une salle
d'audience qui était libre alors je me
suis dit que j'allais faire une vidéo
j'allais lui faire une capture d'écran
j'avais eu envoyé alors effectivement
j'envoie une capture d'écran en disant
salut Damien je suis corrige journaliste
et je viens de tomber sur ça en pleine
audience il me fait un petit smiley avec
une goutte sur le soir sur le front
pardon une goutte de sueur sur le front
alors là évidemment il y a pas la
totalité bien sûr mais sans demander de
contexte sans rien sans vérifier sans
autre explication que
la photo et le petit texte de salutation
que je lui ai envoyé initialement et le
lendemain il diffuse cette photo sur son
compte Twitter j'attends un petit peu
que ça monte parce que je voulais
vraiment le piéger vraiment démontrer
que depuis un certain nombre de temps je
vais reprendre l'expression que j'ai
utilisé dans la vidéo il se fout de
notre gueule et que systématiquement
dans ce pays
alors qu'il y a à peu près 6% de
musulmanes et musulmans deuxième
religion de France systématiquement on
entend toujours parler de l'ultra-droite
de l'extrême droite qui vient
stigmatiser nos compatriotes musulmanes
et musulmans et donc un moment donné il
faut dire STOP voilà vous êtes dit je
vais le piégé donc je lui alors la
méthode elle est peut-être douteuse
c'est un prank peut-être rigolo mais il
est très grave non il y a rien de très
grave mais il y a rien que on ne sait
pas déjà c'est à dire l'islamophobie
ambiante et c'est ça la réalité alors
qu'on est ou pas d'accord avec la
méthode j'ai envie de dire c'est pas
très grave l'idée c'est de démontrer que
finalement ce Damien Rieu et je vais
vous dire et on va des choses à la télé
avec des méthodes voilà par exemple moi
je vais prendre l'exemple on va
s'appelle celle de France 2 là
les méthodes aussi voilà après
ça sert à rien ça va ce qui vous disent
que la méthode est un petit peu triviale
franchement je suis je suis pas d'accord
ça c'est rien du tout c'est bien vu
franchement bravo à vous pour ce que
vous avez fait parce que vous avez
révélé que sur les réseaux sociaux il y
a des gens qui prétendent d'être qui
prétendent être des sources
d'informations fiables puisqu'ils ont
une petite pas si bleue à côté de leur
compte qui en réalité sont juste des
idées des logs extrémistes qui sont
prêts à tout pour répandre leurs idées
nauséesabondes quitte à relayer tout et
n'importe quoi et moi je trouve que ça
pose quand même question sur la manière
dont on relais de l'information sur les
réseaux sociaux je pense qu'il devrait y
avoir des sanctions quand on a un compte
certifié on doit faire attention à ce
qu'on relais donc bravo voilà alors le
seul qui dit non je vais le prendre
forcément c'est Gilles alors pour moi on
ne joue pas avec la religion voilà c'est
pas alors autant d'Amiens Rillieux je
condamne fermement ces idées vous je
trouve que la méthode est pas bien
pour vous vous êtes un provocateur vous
êtes habitué comme ça de prendre des
postures ou des identités et moi ça me
gêne c'est imitation d'un musulman qui
prime voilà je vous le dis franchement
je comprends c'est bien joué vous avez
gagné mais je trouve que vous vous en
tirez à bon compte parce que je suis
obligé de vous dire bien jouer mais moi
j'aime pas qu'on imite comme ça un
musulman qui prient
je veux bien assumer sur cette matière
là d'être totalement réac Cyril mais je
trouve que on ne joue pas avec les
religions quelle que soit la manière
dont on veut jouer voilà
moi aussi je suis comme toi la question
est-ce qu'il faut jouer quand le mec il
tarde dans une église ou peu importe je
déteste qu'on touche à la religion parce
que ça blesse des gens la religion c'est
privé je ne veux pas qu'on joue avec la
religion or là d'abord il s'excuse
auprès de tous les musulmans il le dit
bien et c'est pour mettre le doigt sur
quelqu'un qui salit la religion lui
toute la journée Damien Rieu il fait que
ça même quand les gens sont malades il y
avait une vidéo qui traînait sur dans le
métro ou un train le mec il est malade
mentalement il priait pas il était juste
malade c'est ce qu'il a toute la journée
était dans le métro à faire ça c'est un
malade et lui se sert de ça pour dire
regardez on prie non on prie pas il est
malade le monsieur ça m'a un mental et
quand c'est un Français qui tire sur des
Kurdes j'attends son tweet moi il y a
pas tweet là là par contre il y a pas de
tweet quand c'est les Français qui font
des attentats il dit rien donc lui il
est nocif il est nocif pour tout le
monde parce qu'il est en train de nous
diviser alors si c'est pour la bonne
cause on est déjà assez divisé comme ça
si c'est bon la bonne cause moi je vais
jusqu'à vous dire bravo c'est bien de le
montrer que lui c'est un espèce de mytho
qui fout la merde il y en a marre des
mots des comme dernière Rio comme ça il
y en a marre il y a des problèmes
vous en avez marre de Bernard Montiel
il y a des problèmes on le sait qu'il y
a des problèmes en France on dit pas le
contraire mais lui toutes les deux
minutes la preuve il vérifie rien il met
et en plus il a une caisse de résonance
de fou parce que si vous êtes de retours
mais à chaque fois il a une caisse de
résonance de malade les gens ils croient
je suis comme toi je veux pas qu'on
touche à la religion mais là c'est bien
on a tellement parlé des différences de
religions et dans le temps il y a eu
tellement de guerre de religion moi je
trouve qu'en 2023 la religion ne devrait
plus être un sujet et tout le monde pour
devrait pouvoir prier comme il le veut
et au final que la religion ne soit plus
un sujet mais
là vous prenez ce que c'est dans
l'espace public d'être hyper philosophe
et là je parle même pas de laïcité je
parle même de l'inverse c'est-à-dire que
tout le monde devrait pouvoir faire ce
qu'il veut que sa religion parce qu'au
final on prie la même chose là en haut
et on devrait plus être catalogué par
rapport à nos religions je trouve que
c'est totalement obsolète
dans l'espace public et de créer des
fausses informations
fausses informations j'ai l'impression
que Béatrice t'aime pas
et de me dire on devrait plus parler des
religions aujourd'hui c'est bon quoi
chacun sa religion chacun un peu comme
il veut où il veut Béatrice
moi je trouve ça déplorable de propager
des fausses images et sans vérifier
c'est vrai que la base sur Twitter c'est
de vérifier l'information qu'on qu'on
poste maintenant il y a aussi le sujet
des prières dans l'espace public il faut
pas voilà c'est un sujet on peut en
parler etc mais je trouve pas bien de
publier de fausses informations et de
prendre quelqu'un qui est malade mental
et de rajouter une couche mais ça ne
veut pas dire que tout tout ce qui il y
a quand même il y a quand même on reçoit
des SMS te concernant le ministre comme
ça on dit tout on crève la position
le journaliste Cory Le Guen a fait de la
prison pour s'être fait passer pour le
neveu de Brigitte Macron
on va en prison pour ça afin d'accéder à
des événements ou de résider dans des
hôtels de luxe l'homme de 35 ans usurpé
le nom des contes des directeurs de
cabinets de l'Élysée et c'est de passer
pour le neveu de la première dame de
France dans l'objectif d'obtenir un
accueil VIP avec
oui alors d'une part ça nous fait chier
attendez d'une part ce sont des faits il
était prévu que je ne vienne pas parler
de ça mais peu importe parce que les
tout le monde en paix il y a pas de
souci je pense que c'est des faits qui
date de 2018 pour les juger en 2021
aussi en 2002
c'est passé on parle souvent de
réhabilitation on dit souvent oui ceux
qui ont des casseroles ont des problèmes
avec la justice il faut se réhabiliter
faut se réinventer je suis devenu
journaliste bien après il y a de la
santé
je suis tous les journalistes après et
on me pointe du doigt parce que je me
réinsère et si je me réinsère pas on me
pointe aussi quoi que je fasse on point
des gens qui ont des difficultés de
l'insertion c'est la réalité bien sûr
non mais je te dis donc je trouve que
quand on est Corinne c'est bien d'en
avoir non mais est-ce que tu peux
répondre total et en fait on revient
alors deux choses je voulais revenir
total je fais mon travail des analyses
je te dis on est en train de te
cantonner Corinne non mais
c'est quoi bien marcher cette semaine
[Rires]
tu as fait quoi tu as fait combien de
placard là moins que Moulis non mais
attends c'est un avion
c'est un ami marcono mais dis combien
j'ai fait à peu près 11 mois 11 mois
voilà aujourd'hui il a fait la purée ça
peine les mecs je rappelle juste hein
c'est beaucoup juste
au revoir d'une part vous avez des gens
vous avez des gens qui dans ce pays
100000 personnes chaque année rentre en
prison souvent pour des délits et des
faits mineurs des faits précaires on est
stigmatise systématiquement comme en
stigmatise les musulmans qu'il y aurait
dans ces places de prison moi je visite
des prisons parce que en tant que
journaliste on peut accompagner des
parlementaires ce n'est absolument pas
le cas et j'ai fait mon mea culpa déjà
sur la vidéo et je m'en excuse de
nouveau devant les musulmanes et les
musulmans de ce pays quant aux prières
de rue parce que je vais arrêter sur la
prison c'est passé sur les prières de
rue
de sujets dans votre vidéo en fait je
regrette et je regrette que vous n'avez
pas parlé de rue si Vitas de l'extrême
droite et ça c'est dommage il faut le
parler nous sommes exactement je suis
d'accord avec vous nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un pays dit d'égalité
cette valeur de la République et nous
devons mettre en place soit les prières
de rue pour toutes les religions
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop facile
effoncé après je regarde le sondage vous
avez purgé la peine ok mais quand je
disais tout à l'heure vous êtes un
provocateur c'est que vous vous
revendiquez
attendez vous dites que je me revendique
journaliste donc je suis ou pas
journaliste oui journaliste vous faites
une diffamation vous faites pas
diffamation je suis ou pas journaliste
je suis journaliste ou je suis pas
journaliste oui mais journaliste vous
prétendez journaliste
[Applaudissements]
qui peut t'attaquer avec une immense lui
je critique maintenant
je dis juste c'est pas une méthode
est-ce que vous connaissez c'est une
méthode de journaliste de
oyos bien sûr
de TF1 paix à son âme et vous allez dire
que lui n'est pas journaliste vous
m'agressez mais moi je vous adresses
c'est pas parce que tu es mal dans ta
vie perso tu dois défoncer quoi
je ne supporte pas qu'on joue avec la
religion
je trouve que c'est pas à vous de porter
ses valeurs là il faut il faut combattre
monsieur citoyens citoyen de ce pays de
le porter d'arrêter la stigmatisation
envers les musulmanes et les musulmans
on doit parler quand on dit des choses
qui sont débiles
vous faites une généralité vous parlez
d'une personne en particulier
j'ai toujours dit moi j'aime pas quand
on se moque de la route ça m'énerve ça
m'énerve moi ça m'énerve
chacun fait ce qu'il veut et du moment
qu'il me casse pas les bonbons